below the surface of the earth the quest
to explain the first moments of the
universe is resuming with the help of
the newly upgraded large particle
collider over the last two years the
machines for major detectors have been
fitted with new sensors the physicists
at CERN say the overhaul will enable
them to make their measurements more
quickly and much more accurately
something the scientists have long been
working towards was I'm a lad see what
we will or won't learn with the help of
the LHC will determine the future of
particle physics without a doubt it is a
very important phase and we are all very
excited response starting as early as
June the researchers hope to push the
so-called big bang Collider to its limit
but first the 27 kilometer underground
ring must be fitted with new electronic
components the ring must be capable of
withstanding massive pressures for the
next three years inside the LHC
particles will move faster and collide
more often than previously the
collisions will produce a force greater
than has ever been measured in a
scientific experiment before
the researchers are hoping to discover
dark matter particles that are
completely different from what we now
know it's a discovery that scientists
say could resolve some of the great
mysteries of the universe